five home cooks are ready and raring to
do battle across too demanding grounds
in the hope of impressing celebrity chef
Edward Lee Bell V special tips from
longtime Michelin star chef Gordon
Ramsay and one talented cook will win
$1,000 and become today's culinary
genius
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Samantha Harris and
welcome to culinary genius the show that
tests even the coolest of cooks ability
to work under pressure
today's cooks are getting ready for
culinary battle leave each brought their
favorite secret ingredient or special
item from their kitchen at home to help
them here today and oversee the
competition is a groundbreaking chef
with a whole lot of southern charm
that's right it's Edward Lee
[Music]
all right what do you have lined up for
our cooks today we have a culinary
challenge to test your knowledge now the
three who perform the best get to move
on to the second round which will be a
cook-off all right thank you very much
Edward all right let's reveal what's in
store today
contestants please lift your cloches yes
that is a plate of beef now before we
get started here's world-class chef
Gordon Ramsay on how to get the best
from your beef today you get to work
with this incredible beef now here's a
fact the average American needs 77
pounds of beef per year but for me
whether it's a rib cap a New York Strip
or even a brisket trust me the flavor is
in the marbling without that fat there's
no flavor what would I do
personally I turn a filet into the most
amazing filler beef wellington so Edward
what's our first challenge today today
cooks you must identify seven different
cuts of beef by placing them on the
right part of the cow in front of you
one of the cuts is not from a cow the
three cooks who put the most cuts in the
right place will go through to round two
you have five minutes but the battle
[Music]
okay Edward what are the cuts they have
to identify today today's cuts of beef
are tongue oxtail ribeye New York Strip
filet brisket and skirt steak beef I
know is a huge part of Korean cooking
goodness I can't imagine Korean barbecue
with that beef right you got the short
ribs sliced thin little soy sauce a
little sweet marinade pop it on a hot
grill there's nothing better so many
options with beef what is your favorite
cooking style if money is no object I'm
going straight for the rib eye but
really important you don't spend a lot
of money on a rib eye to overcook it
keep it nice and pink in the center all
right well why don't we go ahead and
check on our
hey there Kelly yeah I can see you're
very squeamish I know you'd like to
usually cook healthy food is this not
your a cup of tea no I don't know any of
these so that's good well guess yeah
yeah I remember more of them on there at
least that gives you a shot one out one
out right definitely
all right Cherise hello you're a flight
attendant I hear yes I am right so you
must have traveled the entire world and
seen cuts of beef from every culture
tell me you know what you're doing you
know in fairness this isn't about fair
this is about knowledge yeah I don't
have any of that this looks like a chunk
he's going on the chunk that's how
you're gonna do you have a lot in place
you shouldn't about where you put
everything at all and I'm like trying to
figure out which is the one that doesn't
belong all right Andy well you're
already done yeah well I mean I've come
from Texas so we know our way around the
town you feel good about this some of
them not all of them
now where'd you bring from home I
brought Szechuan peppercorns my favorite
and tell the audience what Szechuan
peppercorn is so special for corn is the
flower bud of a plant in Asia that's I
got a tingly kind of flavor all right
well I hope you get to the next round
because I would really love to see you
use that's one of my favorite spiced
fish alive you really focused here I
don't want to focus so you have a lot of
people here somewhere
many in the audience is it for you all
right well no probably or they are at
messes up right all right all I know
this one
keep going good luck okay Cherise no
Kelly they're both kind of fumbling
around
[Music]
one now only three can go through to the
final round it is time to find out from
Edward how they should have done it I'm
gonna start with the easy ones okay
so first we're gonna start off with the
top okay and that goes in the head very
good this way the tongue is a very
interesting cut it's got a lot of fat in
there and but it's got this skin layer
on top so you have to cook it low and
slow and then you have to cut this and
peel off the skin layer before you can
heat it but it's really delicious cut of
meat let's go all the way to the other
end to the tail that's the tail got this
little round of cartilage right here and
if you put a bunch of these nuggets
together you'll have one long tail we
usually call it an ox tail but it's
really just a cow's tail really high in
gelatin so when you make a stew out of
this you get this really rich sumptuous
gelatinous - it's beautiful kind of meat
let's move on to what we look like the
steaks first one is going to be ribeye
and this is actually my favorite cut of
beef what you see here is nice marbling
and the sign which you can tell a ribeye
is you've got this little pockets of fat
all around right when you sear off a
stick will melt and just kind of flavor
the meat and that goes right here and
the rib this is strip stick this fat you
want to trim some of it off but not all
of it off cuz this is where all your
flavor is coming from and that's gonna
go right there
now the prized cut of meat of a cow the
tenderloin what you'll notice is there's
not a lot of fat here so what you have
is a cut of meat that you have to cook
very very high sear on the outside but
you have to leave the middle nice and
rare if you cook it too much it's gonna
turn really rubbery really fast and that
goes on the Tenderloin okay next thing
we're going to do is the skirt steak you
can cook this in two ways
you can cook it in a stew low
slow where the meat just sort of falls
apart or you can go really high sear
keep it really rare in the middle and
then slice it into thin steaks against
the grain in which we'll get is this
beautiful textured meat okay and that
actually goes right here on the plate
now what we have here is brisket all of
this meat will kind of fall apart in
your mouth when you cook it low and slow
very difficult to cook quickly it's
something that requires a lot of time
and that goes right here lastly this is
venison leg now you can tell it's not a
part of the beef by the color see how
dark it is compared to that all right so
immediately that should clue you in to
it's saying that this is not a cow and
this goes right over there now let's see
how you guys did back to your stations
[Music]
listen I have high hopes for you being
an international traveler but hey listen
good luck
I think being from Texas you had a
slight unfair advantage but overall
pretty good job you made a Frankenstein
you listen you got the tongue right not
much oh I want to hear this doesn't suck
so bad this doesn't suck okay
so bad listen you didn't get it all
right but not bad at all and you got
that right that's good mmm yeah I'm
seeing some good things and I'm seeing
some worrisome things but hopefully
someone divorced ago that was definitely
a tough around and it's time for five to
become three
[Music]
the first contestant going through to
the final with a score of seven out of
eight is going through with the score of
six out of eight is Scott the final
contestant to go through to the next
round with a score of five is Danielle
Andy Scott and Danielle you are today's
finalists sadly of course that means
that we do have to say goodbye to
Cherise who scored three out of eight
and Kelly you've tried so hard but just
one out of eight you got that Sun right
our three finalists have proved they
have good culinary minds but who will
impress Edward with an incredible beef
dish and win the culinary genius title
so Edward what are you looking for from
our three finalists listen you've got
some incredible cuts of beef here okay
so I want you to respect the meat cook
it perfectly at no overdone steaks
please beef is very dense you've got a
salt properly you don't want bland meat
either want to see some passion don't
forget you can use your cooking
implement or ingredient from home
our pantry is open for you to choose
your ingredients you have two minutes
your time starts
Edward what do we have in the pantry
today there's things like kale asparagus
potatoes if you're doing a classic dish
right we also have horseradish in there
which is a beautiful spice to use you
also have some exotic things in there
there's wasabi Chipotle there's a really
key ingredient ground coffee base which
is really cool to use you can rub steak
with it and there's also dark chocolate
first thing is a complete point because
it's trying to figure out where
everything is and you're trying to find
out one key ingredient you know you need
and you got to find it to see if other
things I'm hoping that we see altano
creativity on these plates
my mind is blank and I'm just rubbing
stuff 10
25 minutes to create a beef dish that is
out of this world so let the final
battle you only have 25 minutes
I see what else did you pick for the
pantry tell us each other so I grabbed
some mushrooms - those you said your
favorite cut was a river I should have
to do a rib are you plan on using the
peppercorns you brought I do yeah tell
me what is the actual dish you're gonna
make here
so I'm gonna do beef two ways one with
an Asian style and one like an American
soil
and so one will put some peppercorns and
then the other bourbon sauce your wife's
a new audience to cheer you on - right
yes that's right all right well get
cooking that's a lot to do it's very
ambitious
okay good night I guess I want to check
out all your ingredients from the pantry
what did you grab first and foremost
bourbon I mean I think it goes with
everything right tell me about your
vegetables that you grabbed - we've got
asparagus coming from California it will
always have great asparagus so I'm gonna
definitely roast that off I see you
found the secret ingredient already this
is uh over this barbecue sauce but the
other smoked paprika some the sugar salt
things I think I'm just gonna do some
roast potatoes do a seared steak but do
with a mustard bourbon reduction sauce
working the asparagus amount all right
you see you've got a pretty classical
approach to the steak I mean you got
some heavy competition here so anyway
it's true sick all right Danielle
Danielle or so soon as I get a knife in
my hallway she's gonna look over your
shoulder the whole time they won't make
me nervous at all know what else you
grabbed from the pantry here a whole
bunch of different lot and inspired
ingredients and plantains are why was
that they really brought from home cuz I
love them and they're delicious
I'm gonna make fried plantain chips
sweet plantains and skirt steak with
some chimichurri sauce I made this dish
before yeah have you made this this
before in 25 min now all right
listen keep focused okay you got some
spills going on keep a clean bore
and is really going for the aggressive
approach of trying to take on two
different flavors two ways to do it
right or you have double the chance to
make a mistake but each single one has
to be properly cooked
if one moon is perfect and the other one
is not guess what I'm judging you on the
one that's not well sometimes less is
better danielle has a Latin chimichurri
skirt steak and she's got a goddess
super thin right it's a tough cut of
meat if she cuts that a little bit too
thick guess what it's just gonna be
chewy in my mouth what would you have
chosen from the pantry and what would
you have done with us make a rib eye
suit up nice make it perfect and juicy
and bloody in the middle you know some
horseradish created over the top I got
some ginger some beautiful asparagus
maybe grill that asparagus put some
parmesan on top you know just give it a
little bit of fancy but stick with the
basics all right cooks we are at the
halfway mark pathway I think I've done
pretty well if I was sitting around
cooking for friends and family I'm not
sure that I nailed it for a world-class
chef crowning today's culinary genius so
I am going in all right Scott we're in
those final moments how are you feeling
um okay you are a marketing director so
are you gonna be really focused on the
presentation here you know I wish I
could say that but my presentation is
probably my weakest skill that's gonna
let it know that like right no I don't
mean I mean all right Andy outpouring in
that bourbon you're gonna make chef ed
very happy there what is it your wife's
favorite dish for you to cook for her
she's Fullerton Tina's but you know they
have a rival de Brasil but she still
likes fish water very very soon bean
stew that's beautiful do you feel that
you're gonna impress your friends with a
meal I mean obviously Edwards the one
you need to really impress today but you
think they would be impressed not my
friends like to eat do you cook for them
a lot
um I cook for my boyfriend oh there you
go
we're the five-minute mark Scott my man
what's going on everything everything's
happening always stopped fire off the
stake we got a steak sauce of trying to
reduce I didn't even know stove top of
the asparagus
nice nice nice you try the oil vinegar
you have a very classic dish right you
have to focus on is every element one
your plate has to be cooked perfectly
okay no mistakes
yes sir it's tough it's you know
stressful you're trying to put things
together he's looking at it he's saying
a whole bunch of things and I'm thinking
oh my gosh I forgot X Y & Z and I just
want to get out of there so I can get
back to cooking Wow
so you're cooking me a meal for eight
people right here is this your steak
resting yesterday okay all right it's
been resting for quite a bit but it has
you're gonna serve me a cold steak or no
I'll try not to okay
did you taste the peppercorns before you
use it I did not actually pull it
together huh holy moly hey listen guys
we need a cleanup crew here something's
wrong we need what's going on here don't
worry about your station so much but
this thing right here has got to look
clean okay please all right this is
making me hungry guys good luck
and it is a little bit flustered right
now you cannot serve cold steak so I
hope you can keep it warm somehow or the
temperature holds because the last thing
you want to do is eat cold steak all
right cooks final minute clocks a-tickin
guys digging deep find your inspiration
put it on that plate the time limit
definitely had me on my ten nine
[Music]
see the final part of culinary genius
where it is time for Edward to judge
what our cooks have created let's go in
doing three cuts of beef it's definitely
a gamble but I thought they'd impress
chef Louie it's gotta be done I think
I've done pretty well if I was sitting
around cooking for friends and family
I'm not sure that I nailed it for a
world-class chef I'm a little nervous
that I put the be fine a little too
quick and then took it off too quick but
I wanted to make sure that it was
medium-rare in the middle and I
definitely didn't want to over cook the
steak let's talk about presentation
first I got a little bit of droop is
this Modernist Cuisine and I've got one
steak that's kind of waving to me
so presentation could be better I saw
you got rushed there right at the end
you were fiddling around with the potato
Canal don't worry about that make sure
the food gets on this way listen the
ribeye is perfect potatoes absolutely
untoward sumptuous as beautiful the
mushrooms are great tenderloin however
it's cold it's dry
I don't know how what you did with the
peppercorns but it didn't quite sort of
make it on there I know you should have
probably dusted at first then sear it on
there you just kind of did it the last
minute part of the this challenge is to
take a risk and you did weren't
completely successful but all this other
stuff was absolutely delicious all right
first of all this is my kind of steak
like we're cooking steak this is what
you're gonna do you're gonna bring it
yep listen you did say that presentation
was trying to be a weak point and I a
hundred percent agree with it yes now I
did see that you kind of rushed that
steak at the last minute here right yeah
needed to get it properly cooked
okay your kale is a little bit
undercooked yeah kind of yeah hooked it
up a little bit more this is a beautiful
stick you're lucky that I like my steak
rim I'm very lucky but rare
everything on here otherwise is cooked
really well
you took a classic approach you did it
well stakes a little bit underdone first
of all this looks like it came from a
restaurant and looks like cocina Daniele
it's a very nice event which is
surprising cuz you were just a mess over
there no it's like it's impossible that
she's ever gonna get anything beautiful
on a plate the tricky thing about a
plate like this is that you have a lot
on there and some of the components
there are flawed and I really have to
judge you on everything that you put on
a plate right so these guys are just a
little bit soggy right and they should
be nice and crispy these plantains
however absolutely delicious the rice is
perfectly cooked the cilantro is really
nice on that the beans are gorgeous I
would have loved to see maybe some more
peppers no kind of something on the
plate and the chimichurri sauce is great
did a lot of components a couple of
flaws and the meat is definitely
undercooked but overall it's delicious
alright I know your pastas gonna be
happy about that one to make so why
don't we go ahead and take a walk
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches same exact this
at many many a Latino restaurant and
yours added up to as good if not better
than most of the right yeah
[Applause]